all right time to get an update on our
local real estate market with harvey
blankfeld he has some pointers for both
buyers
and sellers take a look
welcome to our show this is las vegas
real estate now where we bring you the
three e's
educate empower and engage we want to
help you to make your real estate
decisions
wise ones for you and your family we're
welcome back rocky theaters welcome back
rocky thank you harvey always good to
see you
great to have you back love having you
here uh i know you had something you
wanted to talk to me about you wanted
i have a friend who came to me with her
frustrations about trying to buy in this
market
and there are no homes available
it's tough out there for buyers right
now i tell you there's a bunch of things
as a buyer you need to do
yeah first of all make sure you're well
qualified make sure you've already done
all the work you need to do with the
lender
so when you present your offer you're
presenting the kind of a letter of
approval
that the seller's going to be impressed
with the listing agent is going to be
impressed with they know you're ready to
go
secondly you may want to sweeten your
offer in a variety of ways first of
course money is king
right usually the sellers the seller's
most concerned about money
but there's other things they might be
concerned about when we're pushing the
price so far above
list price and doing that multiple times
the seller might be concerned with
appraisal
so consider waiving the appraisal up to
a certain amount maybe being able to
come out of pocket a little bit extra
money
to cover a shortfall in the appraisal
the other thing is is that
consider maybe paying some of the
sellers costs that might be
traditionally sellers
to say you know what i'm going to pay
the transfer fee or i'm going to pay
some of the hoa fees and i'm tooting my
own horn a little bit but i think it's
important to have an experienced agent
on your side equation because
navigating this market is tricky it's
tough so we've been talking about buyers
but what about the sellers and listers
in this market
you know when you're dealing with
multiple offers there's a whole bunch of
things as a seller you have to consider
first of all do the math you know the
offer itself is not only the biggest
offer is not always the best offer
and the reason i say that is i just
talked about it before maybe it won't
appraise
unless the buyer's willing to go over
appraised value they can write
you know if your house is listed at 450
and they write a million dollars
i got a feeling the appraiser's not
going to get to a million dollars so
i exaggerate for purpose but the point
is is that you want to make sure that
the buyer is going to
get you the most amount of money after
appraisal the other thing is is
consider that letter that you have
compare those letters i i set it from
the buyer side let's look at it from the
seller side
i want a buyer who's working with a
lender that's trusted who wrote a letter
that says
says that they're well prepared and
they're fully qualified to buy the
property
and then also consider the timeline
sometimes it's nice
for the seller to have a little time
after close of escrow in the property
and that's something a buyer can offer
and a seller can accept as part of the
transaction
that makes that transition a little bit
easier on the seller and then finally
again i think you need i think as a
seller you need an experienced agent i
think it's important
to have somebody who can help you
navigate the variety of operas i want to
end
this on a tweet i saw recently more than
20 000 people
moved to las vegas in the first three
months of 2021 is that true
we're seeing population growth like we
did back in the mid-2000s
the good news is however it's very
important to understand this we're not
in the same financial matrix that we
were then
okay buyers of homes right now or first
of all they're not just buying them as a
commodity they're buying them to live in
them
number one and number two they're fully
vetted by lenders if you've taken out a
mortgage
in the last 12 to 15 years you know that
the work's being done to make sure you
can afford that property
give harvey and his team a call at
702-203-1165